[Music]
and it's getting personal new personal
submitted by Lambo versus Ferrari oh I
can't afford either how about that how
about Civic vs. Accord sexier Ferrari
sucks here honestly you could put both
in front of me and I want to know the
difference
oh really I mean like without elevate
yourself in Pico Rivera girl girl I'm
trying which is how you're trying the
feud between Conor McGregor and caffeine
in a suit thank you
yeah this glass seems [ __ ] up what how
do you say correctly safe and not really
[ __ ] up like the momentum the video
you said it right though yeah y'all lost
me Norma Chamitoff
I just try to read it like how it would
like sound like letter-by-letter you
know like I'm good thank you I
appreciate that so you guys are about it
know what it is they got some insane
beef you're a towel man no I thought you
wanted cuz you love it well so I've
heard the build-up and they've been
having crazy tension so it starts back
at the last UFC where they got into a
big-ass could be beat Conor McGregor
pretty much beat his ass and then Conor
McGregor
what's his BJJ coach's name Dylan Dylan
Dennis that little [ __ ] I'm just
kidding he'll kill me but I don't like
him I don't like gel and Danis talking
in each tip yeah yeah he looks like a
Super Mario Goomba yeah like legit look
yeah yeah yeah if you look up a Goomba
right now is exactly what he looks like
not even in a joke he just he just ugly
so he was outside of the cage talking
mad [ __ ] the whole fight is this UFC 229
I don't remember the number and then
this is the one where khabib jumps over
the fence yeah
starts beating on them and then it was
the one that became this big ofc fiasco
yeah we were there
last fight Connors last fight it was
also the same one where a bunch of
copied teammates get suspended for I
think a whole year from the Nevada stick
fighting commission and then khabib is
only for six months but he's so gangster
that he's like if they don't fight I
don't fight so he's like he's pretty
much saying no to a job for a whole year
cuz that's just how down he is and he
goes I don't care take my money like you
eat it like he's more about honor than
anything else but since then they've
been having crazy jabs back and forth
where where Connor he's like pushing
more than like the businessman image and
then Kobe will still treat it well baby
Yakka people still tweet at him pretty
much saying like hey you can have all
the money in the world but that night I
owned your honor
oh that's painful oh yeah so I don't
know this is them just going back in for
this is the whole building people
depending on who the person is wait do
you think like the beef is just like for
like Twitter fingers or like give a site
on the street they really get down it is
without money what was happening within
the ring as they were fighting at the
UFC um he where did he keep twitted nur
Mona get off what did he keep telling
them like oh talk [ __ ] now like say that
now say that now it's all I say it to my
face
yeah say it to my face cragger was like
dude it's just business WordPress it was
just like like like he was trying to
tell him like we just put on a show so
we can sell tickets but for him he
didn't get that he just was like this is
real you're talking [ __ ] about my family
you're talking [ __ ] about my Dreamcast
again so it's a way way different place
where your words actually mean a lot
yeah and you don't say [ __ ] unless you
mean PR all that [ __ ] for him it's like
you're talking [ __ ] about my family I'm
gonna kill you it's a type of place
where if someone's whistling an adult
will come in to smack you and like why
the [ __ ] are you whistling in public so
it's a place where it's like it's
hardcore as [ __ ] that's like the culture
of the place so they don't really [ __ ]
around
so when Carter is talking all his [ __ ]
going around with this [ __ ] monkey
arms right
I think Kobe was pretty pissed about
that stuff so he was like see to my face
it to my face right so I wanted to
believe it was just like marketing yeah
could be marking el corazon angka beeps
and alibiing so i think he really
believes and then before that whole
thing what did you have an economy
burger throwing a dolly through the bus
no oh that was huge news - and it was
like it's all part of the same piece
it's both camps both camps don't like
each other so now more recently they've
still been oh my good night rivalry but
on Twitter and stuff
Twitter fingers so this corner burgers
this could be and I don't know like
again this [ __ ] beef is so long and so
convoluted but here
Connor tweeted your wife isn't tell me
well Biebs wife that's a pretty hard day
his wedding wait the towel I think in
tradition in their route like yeah like
their culture and stuff it's tradition
of the [ __ ] out of roasting you're a
towel wait wait why is it so so because
towel head is a derogatory term Muslims
Muslims oh I feel like when he wrote
that tweet he just said it literally
yeah I think I read it Tapia like not
knowing that the Tariq yeah look at that
slum cuz is that good for it the US
right cuz they are do all countries and
if they say it they know that well I
don't know but it is he's from Ireland
the well the way it's phrased it just
looks very literal it does it doesn't
seem like it was meant to be that way
but I know that he had he did delete
that tweet so he did he did delete it
and then also in the past when he was
doing the boxing fight with Mayweather
thank you how you kept calling him boy
and stuff like he just that seemed like
that's just how he talks but then other
people took that as a racist thing yeah
get over here boy yeah and then the dude
and you could be like 15 and the guys I
hate him that why you calling older man
but because they owned them they call
them boy like all of her doesn't derive
try to be my smaller people were saying
that that was like you know
now he's again being yeah but he's also
Irish I know
and not to excuse his behavior or
whatever but like you can't put American
things on where's my Gregor live here no
oh okay he trains out Walt in Nevada
yeah and then uh could be responded with
rapists you are you are a hypocrite who
is not responsible for your actions
justice will find you we will see and
then you tagged up and so he's because
that's not his girlfriend or commenting
on how now Conor McGregor has like
allegations against him what girl
see the problem with that risk that's
another chick is that his wife or the
problem is is just it's too literal and
Connors was just really funny yeah I
think this guy yeah different like
that's that's that's that's just
indicative of the type of how compatible
like Kobe was very literal right Connor
is this this jokey drunk guy he's a
drummer there's basically what he is so
like throughout this whole like Twitter
interaction thing it's Connor wants this
rematch really bad Oh does he he wants
to fight Kobe I'm sure dude if you got
your ass beat someone you hate reason
why he's tweeting oh [ __ ] I don't know I
don't even know if he has a chance
against him there's a video he was
promoting proper 12 and he was like I'm
an Aussie right now I want a rematch
with you it's just all so he could get a
rematch they saw that it is so he wants
a rematch he's gonna get it but then I
don't think so why if it would cost so
much money yeah it's gonna sell seeds
like like I want to be there could be
bitten Karros oh you think Abby won't
find him again no but wouldn't it be
like well if you don't want to find me
again you're scared like if I beat you
twice I'm if I really beat you well it's
it's not even that cuz he beat up Connor
so [ __ ] bad like um she's like no
we're not doing that the real life's
like Connor was considered like I
wouldn't say the greatest of all time
but he was the first double champ so he
had he had two belts in two weight
classes and he'd beat them decisively
like Eddie Alvarez
what kind of his last fight was terrible
recently but but he killed Eddie I
literally embarrassed Eddie Alvarez and
Eddie Alvarez at that time was
considered a bang and mind you he went
up away classify Eddie Alvarez right and
he [ __ ] starched his ax and showboat
it half yeah so he was walking around
just kicking everybody's [ __ ] ass and
then mind you like after he left we're a
little bit could
he's been undefeated and khabib
everybody was saying that khabib
stand-up wasn't that great right because
he's typically a wrestler right so he
does samba when he grow when he grew up
he was wrestling bears literal bears he
there's something called [ __ ] right and
it's this is a very aggressive type of
wrestling but either way khabib comes in
steps in does an overhand BA almost
knocks Connor out with with hands which
is very unexpected after that he just
smothers him it beats the [ __ ] of him
now mind you in that first round Conor
McGregor actually did a really good job
in defending him they're really great
yeah so you know a lot of people work on
fans right now are saying like if he
gets a chance to do it again I bet you
Connor does have a fighting chance which
I believe what I saw it Conner didn't
look like he was ready at all yeah he
looked like [ __ ] yeah and everybody said
that too when they looked at him it was
like he doesn't look like he has that
same fire in his eyes and then you saw
it in the fight where he got his ass
beat so now Connor
I don't think Connor gives a [ __ ] he
just wants to redemption now you know
what I mean cuz he's by the way he's a
gajillion heir so he already had his
boxing match which floyd method which i
think he made like 40 million dollars
off of what's Wi-Fi which is very
unheard of for an MMA fighter so MMA
fighters at most will probably walk away
with a mil to mil and he's ufc's like
stableboy so he like he just sells
tickets cuz right he's just like so loud
he's such a big personality and you
don't really see that in the UFC yeah
and then now he's demoing retirement oh
he's ready he's retired and they're
saying did he just say it was announced
he announces retirement yeah that's why
yeah he said he was doing that but for a
negotiation tactic because he's trying
to get shares
oh yeah he was yeah that's true and
you've done this before back in 2016
where he announced he was retiring but
it was again a negotiation tactic so
people don't really take him serious for
this there's also this statistic where
it was 90 percent of fighters that say
they retired come back damn any fighter
that says they're retiring is taken with
a grain of salt also like with McGregor
to like I think like I feel like most
fighters they come back cuz they don't
have much else to do but McGregor
there's so much things he wants to do so
if he retires like I'm pretty sure he's
done done but except for this one cuz I
know he wants to fight hope you begin
yeah so like I know like most about it
like for example like Dominick Cruz
Dominick Cruz when he retired he didn't
really think about his future outside of
fighting right so after he got his belt
deathful actually went to a spiral of
depression so they didn't nobody ever
thinks what
laughter I have this belt oh [ __ ] what
next here's happiness yeah and most
fighters - like fighting this is their
whole life so after they retire what
else are they supposed to do this is
what they're used to this is their daily
[ __ ] grind yeah 24 [ __ ] 7 after
they say ok I'm too old to fight which
sucks because the only reason why
they're not fighting isn't because they
don't want it it's because their body
says no yeah so that's why they go to it
other other publications well other
fighting stuff outside of UFC like
Bellator alright so Bellator they take a
lot of like UFC retired fighters like I
love Bellator but - by the way but
you'll see them fight over there they go
for Bellator they'll go to other stuff
like Alaskan fighting champion yeah I'll
go all over the place
just because that's all they know how to
do but then Conor he has proper 12 put
multi-million dollar whiskey company but
nothing replaces that excitement and
that spark yeah I kind of it's so
interesting because when he was asking
for a piece of the UFC a lot of people
feel weird about it right because Conor
people say well well this is Dana's this
is Dana's response Dana says well you're
not the only fighter out that there's
gonna be more people like you after and
the other people's argument is is there
really because it took X amount of years
for there to be one [ __ ] cop yeah
there's never been another Connor before
Conor ie there's two other people that
are trying to follow Connors footsteps
right now and they [ __ ] suck Coby
Covington and Dylan Dennis you guys are
the two trashiest human beings not
because not because of how trashy their
look is is because they're doing it so
they can get caught but it's not working
because it's so fake it's so cringy it
just it's like it's to the point where
people were watching them just to hate
them now but because they do that same
[ __ ] over and over it's like nobody
[ __ ] cares yeah like they could
literally die tomorrow and nobody would
care yeah and that's how bad it is it's
like they're so desperate like Dylan
Dennis recently put up a video on his
Instagram of a this one [ __ ] insta
hope just grinding on his his girlfriend
or some [ __ ] it's just her just grinding
on him like he's in bed it's like come
on bro like it doesn't it doesn't even
suit you you Goomba like I'll [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] dude but I don't know like
it's it's such an odd thing because you
you can't deny that Conor McGregor did
bring up the value of UFC and if Connor
did want to argue what he goes well I
literally brought this sport to another
level like Ronda Rousey did right and
like people didn't know about the UFC as
much they did before I stepped in and
then you guys sold to ESPN for a
kajillion dollars yeah right and mind
you before back in the day I think they
offered Chuck Liddell was it a piece of
the heart of that yeah right yeah so why
wouldn't they give Connor a little bit
to know he's so that's his argument like
I'm either way like I wouldn't see it if
I don't know how much he's asking for
but if somebody takes your company and
elevates it that high until this day
he's not just a ticket seller like he's
literally brought a new style of UFC in
like legit nobody was promoting the
sport like they did there he's promoting
it like boxing that's how boxers did it
yeah yeah you know what I mean like with
ollie like [ __ ] Muhammad Ali used to
just talk mad [ __ ] he was like the first
one that started doing it I think but
because he's elevated the sport that
much I do believe that if he says he
wants a piece just to keep him in why
not give him a little bit or something I
don't know so back to this Twitter
picture
so then Connor said I smacked her
brother around and took a [ __ ] you think
you said if you think that insulting
entire religion you be safe you are
mistaken
and then Connor said I want to move
forward with my fans of all faiths and
all backgrounds office challenged us to
be our best selves it is one world and
one for all now see you in the Octagon
and then Dana White will see an octagon
ah he said I am aware of the recent
social media exchange between Kabir and
Connor the ongoing situation has
escalated to a level that is acceptable
as such we're taking the necessary steps
to reach out to both athlete camps and
the situation is being addressed by all
parties internally and then they were
mentioning too that the code of conduct
and the UFC like this whole beef here is
completely going against that so yeah
because they're putting new rules in now
right like you can't talk certain [ __ ]
team they added this code of conduct and
so now they're saying that they can use
this to like find both fighters because
they're going against the code of
conduct or like you know forbid them
from doing any more fights or kick them
out of the UFC I don't know but they
gonna do that [ __ ] five people on us for
sure nobody's gonna [ __ ] throw away
money like that there's no other fighter
on the roster that brings that's gonna
bring in money like those two not even
John Jones
yeah not even John Jones
John Jones is so sad to me now well yeah
I mean John Jones cut is so weird just
because like watching him fight now
like I just I for some reason I don't
care like I really don't care stuff like
his last fight I saw it but I didn't
care as much as before just because he's
been there's too much controversy around
him like I just don't care about him as
a sportsman anymore even though I love I
love watching him fight but it won't
make me want to watch fight as much as
I'll watch like I've even Connor fight
oh yeah you know what I mean or even
like even somebody like [ __ ] uh is
this like Israel out of Sanya like I'd
rather watch it
[Music]